The last couple of weeks have been a rollercoaster. I'm sorry to hear that. I think I experienced
my first healing crisis. I retired from my job of 20 plus years and had my quarterly CT
scans. All things are pointing to positive. Thank you, Lauren. But I'm dealing with some
aftermath. I've accomplished a few coffee animals. Is it common to have a metallic or bitter taste
afterwards or even a dull feeling of indigestion? I do really enjoy the mind clarifying. So why
would a person get some clarity of mind if you're doing a coffee animal? Because you're stimulated
in parasympathetics. In the parasympathetics, I've said, do a lot of good things that stimulate
your immune system. They stimulate your detoxification pathways. But I haven't talked a lot about
is it stimulates the rest of relaxation. You're a logical pathway in your brain. So it can be
very comforting and relaxing to your brain. So coffee animals can be very beneficial for that reason.
Can you get a metallic or bitter taste afterwards? Well, it's possible with a coffee
animal to have that. I'm not sure if it's connected directly to the coffee animal. I don't know.
There could be a neurological. I don't know. I could think about that.
I've experienced a lot of past anxiety that I would feel daily with my job.
anxious to start my day, night sweats, work related dreams, any tips to cope through this temporal
emotional problem? But it's like I still have nightmares about testings that I didn't study for
the test. And I haven't gone to the class all semester. And I'm in trouble. And that was 35
years ago. So it is when you have this performance type anxiety, yeah, there's some things to work
with. The coffee animals will help with that. Adaptogens. So the first thing you think of with any
about anxiety is adaptogens. The second thing you think of with anxiety is making sure you are
watching your glutamate consumption. So glutamates, originates, what's the most common glutamate?
monosodium glutamate. Where do you get that? Just what any prepared meal is about any restaurant
we go to. You're going to be consumed. You're going to be consuming monosodium glutamates.
Well, glutamates, why would they put glutamates in food? Because they stimulate your brain.
Glutamates are an excitatory neurotransmitter. And it makes you think, wow, that was really
tasty. And I want to eat that again. That's why they put glutamates in food. Because it makes you
buy the food again. And so glutamates will increase anxiety and increase so CD. And increase
ramped up behavior and looping it out of thought. And you know, thinking about a subject and
can't get your mind off of you, can't let it go. And that is a glutamate issue as well.
Also could be an elevated serotonin level. Serotonin can do similar things when it's elevated.
That's why you have to be careful with taking excess methyl groups. So this because you have a
MTHFR gene defect does not mean you need a whole bunch of methyl groups that can produce excess
serotonin, especially if you have any MTHFR gene defect. That's a gene that is in your body after
the pathway that you want to make sure you look at your genes. So you don't want to excess methyl groups,
but none of you are adding excess methyl groups for us. That's for sure. Because they can also
turn off, turn off to the surface of genes and we don't have you taking any of those. But
also I would say given that the night sweatses in there that you commented on, adaptions would be
my first choice because it can be tied to hormones too. So adaptogenic herbs, we have multiple
different adaptogens on our website. You probably have some in your home too. If you search
adaptogens on our website and you're looking at some of the ingredients you probably have a couple
bottles with nutrients that are adaptogens in them too. Number three, my blood work looks like I am
now anemic. My energy is low, lots of naps, I've done some blood rebuilding with the right. How many
sessions could I do back to back? There's no limit to how many sessions you could do with the right
back to back. Any other strategies to consider. I am also trying to get more protein back in my
mind. The V vitamins will help build your blood and then you may have to consider it. So it depends
on how anemic you are. However, there's multiple types of anemia. If you have anemia, but a disease,
you also have your blood cells. If you have anemia, folate, that's an issue. That's different. If you have
anemia, B12, that's very common. So taking the drugs of normally might be the order two. If you're going to
take iron, whoever you start by iron, put a call or you take iron and mess it up with it.